last week you
talked a little bit about omicron the
new variant uh that we are all supposed
to be quite terrified of
uh there is um
we've been involved in some
conversations about what what it is what
it means what um what it actually
actually we've talked about for the last
two weeks i guess
um
and it's hard to to find
real data right it's hard to find actual
information
and the oregon health authority which i
get missives from as i have mentioned
several times on this show um came to
the [ __ ] rescue this week awesome
with everything you ever wanted to know
about the omicron variant um so i'm
going to put this up um i'm going to
have you not quite yet zach but i'm
going to have you put it up on my screen
just briefly
and then take it down while i read to
you guys what i learned from the oregon
health authority this week about omicron
so here it is omicron what we know about
this new variant
all right um
number so as i just
i don't want you guys getting ahead of
me um
it's five it's five points
color-coded i don't know what the colors
mean though so maybe it's not
color-coded five points omicron what we
know about this new variant i was so
eager to hear with the oregon health
authority oh totally i mean what do the
data say what do the data say one
viruses like sars cov2 the virus that
causes cova-19 mutate or change
constantly
two
all over the world
scientists are studying the omicron
variant
three
we know how to protect ourselves and
others against infection get vaccinated
if you're eligible a booster wear mask
in indoor public settings or outdoor
credit settings keep physical distance
and wash hands frequently
four
oregon health authority is monitoring
omicron
closely
and five and you can put my screen up
now if you like zack as we learn more we
will share information on how you can
best protect yourself and keep your
loved ones and your community
safe
i mean among other things the oregon
health authority has revealed that they
in fact know nothing about omicron
and have nothing to share and really
shouldn't put this into their missive
because they have just further reduced
the confidence that they
know anything and have anything to offer
this may be i mean it's it's a
it's a low bar at this point like for
worst
so i didn't i'm not sure i haven't
reversed a sign there but like could
this be the worst messaging we've seen
so far at least it's not it's not
misinformation it's just no information
it's a information completely empty well
it reminds me of the uh i was just
trying to find it but the
terror threat level color coding system
which was a very useful system you'll
recall for avoiding since like after 9
11 yeah after after 9 11
the government uh actually in
conjunction with the red cross
put together a very informative resource
about how you should respond to the
different terror
threat levels is this going to be at the
level of like duck and cover well it was
as i recall it um
you know you had green through
red and green was
there's no threat of terrorism which i
guess would be equivalent to the
extinction of humanity which would be
the end of the threat of terrorism i
mean you've seen like squirrels going
after each other i feel like squirrel
terrorism is a possibility this world
terror is a thing i don't know about
okay okay you don't think it's organized
right no no i okay but in any case green
is an unattainable goal green is an
unattainable goal so you sort of start
at yellow and yellow is like well
terrorism is possible today
and uh you know
yellow had it had some some pretty
useful stuff in it you know you should
probably
have a plan and you might want some
supplies because
things like that right and so okay
that's good i think a plan a plan
oh and i think you were supposed to
listen to authorities if they provided
information on what you should do right
um and then every level on top of that
basically just revisited the things they
had already told you you need to do um
but with like greater urgency like
definitely listen to authorities and
things like that
make sure those supplies are still great
yeah check your supply exactly so it was
just empty there was nothing there it
was just completely emotional
manipulation by color coding right no
it's not a green day i mean i wonder
that it speaks a little bit to this you
know the tyranny of metrics thing you
know there's it except in that case
like the color coding there's like an
implied
numeric there's an implied ranking right
so there is this
you know implication of quantitative
thinking that has gone into it and
they're just not bothering us with the
numbers don't worry about that but you
know
in all you have to do is like plug in to
we've used numbers and you get people to
go along with it
yeah no well but i think the point
really is
you're you're not
you know what it is it's um
it's public policy where they forgot to
replace the
what is it laura mipsum
you know
somebody put together all right you know
what we really need we need a you know
like a
five points what we know about omicron
right and
all over the world scientists are
studying right which is literally the
only like that's actually the most
that's oh two of them actually mention
omicron at all the other one being
oregon health authority is monitoring
omicron but you can imagine right if you
knew that there was a you know five
points you need to have about omicron
and you just wanted to like rough some
stuff in and then you were going to come
back later and then you got distracted
and then somebody
right exactly it would be that and you
know that was the terror threat level in
which case we actually i believe
discovered i mean the whole reason that
it's not like terrorism has gone
anywhere when's the last time you saw a
color code for where we are at threat
level right they got rid of it because
you know everybody sort of understood it
was a political manipulation tool
designed to just sort of you know you
know amp your amygdala or whatever right
um and so okay how many times are we
going to fall for this crap right the
pretense that there's information in
there about omicron yep
i mean even if it was five questions
here are five things to watch out for
things we'd like to know about omicron
right
you know
how you know how virulent is it that's a
very important question because how do
you know this could be a great thing
right if it's if it's very mild symptom
wise and produces lifelong immunity it
could save us from this vaccine madness
and the insanity of our public health
response as we said several weeks ago um
does overcrowd like delta before it
seemed to evade the vaccines hmm
interesting question right so you could
you could say here some things to watch
out for but you can't say here here are
the things you need to know and then not
say anything
[Music]
you